Huh?
Still got to tweak it.
Oops, sorry.
Can we make it come here?
Yeah, I mean
Yeah, it's okay. Just Just bring it like
this. I'll make it work.
Thank you.
Looks a surgery
arm.
[Silence]
Continuing in Riyadh al-Salihin
and the 9th the 18th or 19th book of
Riyadh al-Salihin
,
for those of us who have children
I don't know if you've seen it, but
right across the hallway there, there's
this huge giant room.
It's almost it was built just to be
played in. It's a gym. All the kids can
go over there and play until they turn
blue in the face. We'll let them. It's
open right now.
So,
continuing in kitab al-manthurat
wal-mulah
and the narrations regarding
ad-dajjal and the signs of the day of
judgement, the signs of the hour.
Today we have a narration on the
[Arabic recitation]
anhu.
An nar Rasul Allah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam qala
[Arabic recitation]
al-Muslimūna al-Yahūd.
Hatta yakhtabi'a al-Yahūdiyyu min warā'i
al-hajari wash-shajari fayaqūlu
al-hajari wash-shajari, "Yā Muslim,
hādhā Yahūdiyyun khalfī, ta'āla
faqtulhu."
Illa al-gharqada, fa'innahu min shajari
al-Yahūd. Al-hadīthu inda al-Bukhāri
wal-Mus-
wal-Muslim. This narration is collected
by both Bukhari and Muslim.
It talks about and the way that and
Nawawi rahimahullah placed this
narration is very critical here.
We know that when ad-dajjal emerges,
he's going to emerge from a land by what
name?
Asfahan.
And this is a land that is in the
northern we'd say north
northwest
part of modern-day Iran today.
And when he emerges, he will be followed
initially
by 70,000
of the Jews
of that area.
Now, the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam describes
that they will
come out and emerge wearing a green
cloak, all of them.
This kind of imagery where you have a
leader who claims to be God
and then you have followers that all
wear exactly the same clothes
and they have a proprietary color
and a proprietary form of clothing.
What is this exactly? In modern days, we
call this what?
It's a cult.
It's a modern-day cult. That's exactly
what it is.
And so
the issue here is that the Jews, the
Jewish religion, is not all one people.
Allah S.W.T. says
that it appears that they are all
united, but in truly they are divided in
their hearts.
Our prophet S.A.W.
also tells us
in a narration which was collected by
Abu Sunan
[Arabic recitation]
have divided into 71 different groups
and sects, all of them fighting with
each other, all of them claiming to be
the one true follower of Musa A.S.
The prophet S.A.W.
further tells us
that and this is in the Quran, of
course, we all know this, that
the
in the Jewish religion those who
currently are Jewish, those who
remained as Jewish,
that Isa Alayhis Salaam was not
considered to be a prophet. He was not
considered to be a messenger. As a
matter of fact, few of them, few groups
even consider him to have been a
scholar.
And that's the epitome of what they will
ascribe to him. But many of them will
refer to him as a charlatan or a false
prophet.
Now,
they're still waiting
for a Messiah.
They're still waiting for
Isa Alayhis Salaam. Not Isa, but the
person who was to come with his
descriptions.
Isa, they disbelieved in him
and now they are waiting for him still.
This Messiah that will emerge, Ad-Dajjal
will fit that script and fit that bill.
The descriptions of Isa will have been
so distorted
that
Al-Masih Ad-Dajjal, and this is why he's
referred to as Al-Masih Ad-Dajjal, he
will emerge and claim to be that Messiah
that they were awaiting.
Now, that group of people that will
muster around
Ad-Dajjal, they will
form his most
intimate army. Those are his closest
followers.
And the prophet Sallallahu Alayhi
Wasallam tells us that
we will have two camps at that time.
We will have the camp of Ad-Dajjal
and his 70,000 followers and whoever
else he was able to
bring into his fold. and Ad-Dajjal
will last how many years on the earth or
how many days? 40 days. The first day
will be a year, and the second like
a month, and the third a week, and
the rest of the days will be as average
days. When we get to that 39th day
and Ad-Dajjal's end is eminent and
looming.
The Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us that the conflict between
Ad-Dajjal and Al-Mahdi, so we will have
the camp of Ad-Dajjal and we will have
the camp of Al-Mahdi with his followers.
They will be in Masjid al-Aqsa at that
time.
And they will be there preparing for
salat al-fajr.
And Ad-Dajjal and his army will be at
the gates.
And they are preparing to go to what
appears to be an unwinnable
war with Ad-Dajjal.
At that time, Isa ibn Maryam will
descend.
The Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
tells us that he will descend between
two angels.
And his narrations will come. We will
read them in the following days,
inshallah. That when he descends, he
will descend in which city? Dimashq.
He will then head to
al-Aqsa and find Al-Mahdi and
his followers, the Muslimin there,
preparing to make fajr, and they will
have called the iqama for fajr.
And just as Al-Mahdi is about to lead
salah,
Isa ibn Maryam will walk in.
[Arabic recitation]
Could you imagine?
I mean, it's
Sometimes when you really think, sit
down and imagine
the companions
who were able to meet the Prophet
[Arabic recitation]
or the companions of Al-Mahdi who will
have the
incredible honor
to meet Isa ibn Maryam alayhis salaam
that he will enter the masjid at this
moment.
And Al-Mahdi will then
stand back and insist that Isa alayhis
salaam lead the salah.
And Isa alayhis salaam will say
Innama
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam takrimatan li hadhihil ummah.
And so
he will step stand back for Isa alayhis
salaam to lead Fajr,
and he will say, "No, the iqama was
called with you in mind to lead." And
Isa will stand in the row behind him,
and Al-Mahdi will lead salah. The
Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
commented on this image.
He said, "This is out of honor of this
ummah."
That Isa alayhis salaam
the great messenger of Allah
will
stand and be led in salah by a follower
of Muhammad sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
After which, when salah is over, he will
inform them of their places in paradise.
And then he will command that the gates
be opened.
And when the gates are opened, ad-Dajjal
will see Isa ibn Maryam alayhis salaam.
And immediately he will turn tail and
run.
And he will run towards modern day Tel
Aviv, what they call Tel Aviv now. It is
actually Bab al-Lud.
That is the name of that area that is
Do we know the airport there in Tel
Aviv, which is called Ben Gurion? It's
named after the alleged founder and
revivalist of the modern state of
Israel.
That airport is exactly where Bab al-Lud
is today.
Which is interesting, right? Why did he
go there? Is he headed to the airport?
[Arabic recitation]
But that's where the airport is. But he
wants to get out of town. We know that.
Right? The party's over. He's got to go.
He just remembered that he left the
stove on at home,
and he's got to go turn it off, right?
He forgot He forgot his clothes in the
wash. So,
he's going to turn and run.
And of course, his coward followers will
turn and run as well.
Those are the Yahud
that are spoken about in this narration.
Those men and women that make up the
army of ad-Dajjal.
Those individuals
will then face off with the Muslimeen.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will purge
the earth from ad-Dajjal and his
followers.
How will this happen?
Our prophet tells us that ad-Dajjal
will begin to physically melt
just salt in water as he is being
pursued by Isa Alayhis Salaam.
And his troops will start hiding
wherever they can
cockroaches when the light turns
on. They will go behind trees, go behind
rocks, hide under cars, whatever it is.
And Allah will physically make the earth
beneath their feet,
the trees that they hide behind, the
stones that they seek shelter behind
to physically speak and say, "Oh Muslim,
this Yahudi is behind me. He's hiding."
Except for one type of tree.
And that is which tree?
Al-Gharqad. Al-Gharqad is the most
planted tree in modern-day Palestine
today.
Al-Gharqad has been planted This is
going on ever since I was a kid. I think
they really started planting Al-Gharqad,
and it's a useless tree. It doesn't have
any fruits on it. It is just made out of
thorns. Our prophet tells us it's a
nuisance tree, kind of the ones who
plant it. It is a nuisance tree. It
serves no
mentionable
purpose. It doesn't grant anyone shade.
You go and sit under it, you get a bunch
of thorns in your in your behind. And so
it punishes you for seeking any kind of
shelter or benefit from it. But this
tree is, as the prophet says, the only
tree that will try to conceal them.
And this is
the most planted tree. there is an
official government sponsored program
just to plant a olive
all around Al-Aqsa and all around these
areas and those villages and the most
ripped out and
uprooted trees in Palestine are the
olive trees.
And so these trees, these stones, the
earth will be so rid of this scum
that they will begin to speak and say
someone is hiding behind me. Someone is
hiding underneath me. Someone is hiding
beside me.
And Isa Alayhis Salaam will continue to
pursue Dajjal until he catches him
where?
At the airport. What is the
airport today? Exactly the airport is
built at Bab Lud. Exactly.
And it is between
Al-Quds and modern-day Tel Aviv. That is
where Ben Gurion Airport is is
is today. And he will
catch him there at Bab Lud and he will
spear him. He will drive his spear
through him. Now he's already melting.
Physically melting.
Why does Isa bother to kill him even
though he's already melting?
if he would have left him, he would
just melt into nothingness. That's what
the prophet tells us Sallallahu Alayhi
Wasallam that he will begin to dissolve
salt in water. And if Isa would let
him, he would continue to dissolve into
obscurity. Why does he bother to kill
him?
What happens to leaders when they
check out?
If he dissolves, it could be said, "Oh,
he didn't disappear. He just he's going
to come back.
He wasn't killed. He left and he came up
somewhere else. He's going to return."
No, here's the spear on your way out.
And so, he will slaughter him there at
Bab al-Ludd.
And this will mark the end of the Dajjal
and his fitna on the earth.
As soon as this happens,
the
Yajooj and Majooj will be released and
will charge upon humanity. We will
discuss
Yajooj and Majooj fee ma ba'd in sha'a
Allah. And once al-Mahdi and ad-Dajjal
and then subsequently Isa ibn Maryam
descends, once these events happen, the
day of judgement is impending,
meaning
that generation, it is within a
generation or two.
[Silence]
Just
a
quick mention, we've mentioned it
before, but you know, congratulations
is in order to our graduates. I don't
really see any of them except for Abdur
Rahman, masha Allah. Congratulations,
you know, I'm sure that I know for a
fact your your father is incredibly
proud of you and as well he should be.
Fine young man, masha Allah, as they are
all of them. Congratulations to them and
their parents. Thank you all for coming
this evening. We'll just have a little
fire on. Wa sallallahu wa sallam ala
[Arabic recitation]
I think the
The wire is too tight in there. That's
why it's
It looks
It looks It looks a little bit
futuristic very futuristic
used to be known
for this
As my father left